but Lord of the Ring Trilogy if you see
it back to back
Dunder Mifflin this is Pam it's
Michael what's wrong
okay wait wait wait
Michael do you need me to call an
ambulance
okay wait a second I thought you said
that you were hurt
but I need you to come and pick me up
no God hey whoa Michael oh God it's okay
it's Jim just say again really loudly uh
what happened okay I burned my foot very
badly on my Foreman grill and I now need
someone to come and bring me into work
you burned your foot on a Foreman Grill
I enjoy having breakfast in bed I like
waking up to the smell of bacon sue me
and since I don't have a butler I have
to do it myself so most nights before I
go to bed I will lay six strips of bacon
out on my George Foreman Grill then I go
to sleep when I wake up I plug in the
grill I go back to sleep again then I
wake up to the smell of crackling bacon
it is delicious it's good for me it's a
perfect way to start the day
today I got up I stepped onto the grill
and I clamped down on my foot that's it
I don't see what's so hard to believe
about that
Michael all right
I'm sorry
from the chocolate powder just went down
my throat I'm stopping now is this why
you're calling me no no no no no no no
no
I'm calling you
I'm sorry okay
I'm calling because
I'm an early bird and I'm a night owl so
I'm wise and I have worms
wow oh breakfast I got your sausage egg
and cheese biscuit yummy yummy thank you
Ryan
what was the thing uh you needed me to
come in early for
um
the sausage egg and cheese biscuit but
thank you and why don't you just
take a couple hours office is yours Home
Alone Risky Business
take your pants off run around
whatever you ought to do
I'm just gonna take a nap in my car till
work starts okay
Dunder Mifflin this is Aaron
he's not available right now
uh-huh
yes
sure I'll give you a message when he
gets up gets back
Michael had chicken pot pie for lunch
actually let me rephrase that Michael
had an entire
chicken pot pie for lunch and let me be
more specific Michael ate an entire
family-sized chicken pot pie for lunch
and then he promptly fell asleep so
we're all trying to be very quiet so as
to not wake him up before 5 PM which
actually should be in about
10 minutes
okay I'm gonna go in there and change
the computer are you sure you can change
his watch I can do it what do you need
from me
normally I don't condone leaving early
but I have an appointment with the horse
doctor how that horse became a doctor I
don't know
no I'm kidding he's just a regular
doctor who shoots your horse in the head
when its leg is broken
foreign
work
oh
[Music]
okay geography joke oh
oh wow okay all right let's all go home
come on
see you all to Molly
see you later Michael
Scranton business park there will be
complimentary pretzels available in the
lobby from now until four o'clock as a
thank you to our wild time
once a year they bring in a little cart
and they give away free pretzels
it's really not a big deal
to some people it is
productivity is important but how can I
be productive if I have this one little
thing in my brain that I cannot get out
and that one little thing is a soft
pretzel
so I'm just gonna have my soft pretzel
I'll get to work and I'll be super
productive look out for me
oh
shh hi please tell me you have sweet
pretzel left we do
and we have 18 different toppings we
have sweet glaze cinnamon sugar
chocolate white chocolate fudge M M's
caramel dip mint chip chocolate chip
marshmallows nuts toffee nuts coconut
peanut butter drizzle Oreos sprinkles
cotton candy bits and powdered sugar
is there any way that you could do all
all of them the works you got it all
right thank you
it's a little early for ice cream it's
never too early for ice cream Jim
but we didn't have any ice cream
so this is mayonnaise and black olives
oh it's comfort food all right
God yo Michael this old Donna thing is
gonna be okay you just stop beating
yourself up I know well I hope you're
right we'll see what Dwight says why do
we have to see what Dwight says because
I have him investigating her I'm waiting
for a tech stop Michael no no no no no
no undo that undo that it's too late to
undo it I need to know otherwise this
thing is going to spiral out of a muck
Michael
I'm I'm going to talk straight
look at you you have a major
self-destructive streak in you
oh and you you kind of torpedo every
romantic relationship you're in that's
not true
and I've known some wonderful women
Holly Carroll Jan Helene
Pauline my mother oh my mother Helene oh
yeah yes yes yes all of all of the
greatest loves of my life
you should stop this
excited everybody freaking out cool
gonna be fun you're late thank you but I
forgive you because doffit is my
birthday
what's up
hey
oh happy birthday ah thank you sir
Michael's birthday uh it's pretty fun to
watch actually he gets very excited and
then he eats a lot of cake and then he
runs around the office then he has a
sugar crash in the afternoon and then he
falls asleep
and that's when we got our work done
somebody brought in donuts for my
birthday
happy birthday thanks
who brought in Donuts somebody got
donuts for my birthday
happy birthday you didn't know it was my
birthday I guess I forgot well I guess I
forgot to give you a donut
you're serious hmm
[Music]
started stop what is that
for the longest time by William Joel
it's your favorite song yeah I want to
try the radio my birthday blows
nobody even signed my birthday poster
apparently my mother
is the only one who cares enough to send
me anything I probably care more than
she does you make it worse
I bet Luke Perry's friends don't treat
him like this
okay Wendy
hot and juicy redhead
give this a try
Wendy's hello Wendy this is Kevin's
friend Michael
Wendy oh I'm sorry could you put her on
please dude this is a Wendy's restaurant
okay
um
could I just have a frosting a baked
potato please
well send somebody to pick it up just
have it ready
well I'll put it aside
um